so stars came out to raise money for
hurricane relief and if you of course
brought their opinions on climate change
which is great I always go to musical
artists from my science rights TV anyone
who believes that there is no such thing
as global warming must be blind or
unintelligent lord please save us all
save us all indeed so if you agree with
them you're either blind or dumb okay
anyway that's not divisive at all but I
know what you're thinking what's Beyonce
got to say the effects of climate change
are playing out around the world every
day just this past week we've seen
devastation from the monsoon in India
and 8.1 earthquake in Mexico and
multiple catastrophic hurricanes I'm
alone has left a trail of death and
destruction from the Caribbean to
Florida to southern United States we
have to be prepared for what comes next
video so there you have it climate
change caused the earthquake in Mexico
so does this political stuff at a
telethon bug you maybe but it really
shouldn't given that they raised 44
million bucks listening to a few
misguided sentiments from naive
millionaires seems too far again and
yeah calling viewers dumb is pretty
arrogant
I guess stars know that being in a
telethon creates a shield that allows
you to lecture safely from the perch of
sanctimony but still if they want to wag
a finger it's still 44 million bucks
that's a mountain of dough so I can take
one night of chiding by people who stuff
his choices in life or whether fly
private or just take a yacht so
regardless of politics everyone should
do their part we've all given and we've
asked others to do so too and many have
pitched in including sister Margaret
chainsaw
[Music]
it looks like a horror film but Jesus
she lent a hand in a chainsaw and
without pummeling the public with their
politics that's what I call a good it
was a terrible plan works but I want to
shoot this was a beautiful little
interview that Sandra Smith did with
sister Margaret from Miami who found
this chainsaw in a school where she
worked rolled that little thing that
chainsaw was sitting in the closet at
the school it wasn't helping anybody so
I went in pulled it out and just did
what I could to clear that road and to
help other people out people were
driving by taking pictures and telling
me thank you and as I was doing that I
was just praying for other people people
that lost their homes and everything
they really had it bad Dana I don't
think I would be doing that cuz I
wouldn't know how to turn out a chainsaw
bringing because she seemed to really
know how to handle not worried at all I
mean it's not easy I don't think it's
easy actually I don't know that song by
Brian Howe by given with the Democrats
did to one of the president Trump's
Catholic nominees last week for the
judiciary I would suggest that they
consider somebody like this the dogma
obviously lives strongly in her because
she got out there to help people that's
what she was doing
I'm can I say something about the
celebrities yes okay if everyone were to
admit that we have a problem and that
global warming and it's anthropogenic
meaning that it is that humans are
exacerbating in hmm what then mm-hmm
what are they willing to do where is
that advocacy because they never get
beyond just shaming people and not
changing their own behavior right
they're not gonna give up the the plane
they wouldn't have to rich people are
not gonna have to do yeah they all flew
private jets to get to the telephone
yeah by the way if you think about the
name JJ Watt he did what did he raise
like 42 million I think it would birdie
million 30 million without the carbon
footprint of a concert having said that
though I can't complain why because I
mean you raise 44 million bucks
that's you I'll take whatever you say
right yeah by the way I would love to
see you in a habit I think you'd be so
cute I would hug you maybe you have a
little bit of a weird man crush
what I was trying to say before I think
I think when I watch these folks I just
I'm grateful for what they did as you
point out that's a lot of money and they
did in an hour it wasn't like you know
all day Labor Day and I'm like that but
I will say that when you hear Stevie
Wonder when you hear Beyonce say this I
don't think that they know what they're
talking about I think they're just
basically saying what they think is you
know gosh there seems to be a lot of
crazy stuff going on in the weather but
when I hear Scott Pruett who should know
what he's talking about say oh it's
insensitive darlings insensitive to
bring up climate change I think wow are
you trying to avoid reality you're not
willing to have the discussion and you
were afraid of it and you're in charge
of things like oh no cap and trade
debate I think when he when he said that
he was talking about in the immediate
aftermath and while people are still
needing rescue that that wasn't so in
other words at the moment when there
should be a heightened public awareness
of this issue he's saying shut no he
said at that very moment when people
were being rescued it wasn't the right
time but no one else was willing to do
wait a second we got the nun out there
we've got so many people raising money
rescuing people it didn't stop any
wrestling to have a discussion look
we've been done out of this lesson you
know having been educated and partially
raised by nuns and the Sisters of Mercy
for over a decade god bless them you
know nuns do it better I mean just look
at that that is a perfect example and I
think it's fantastic that's America at
its best and we can have all the
discussion we want to think discussion
is healthy that's where Jessie I just
want to make did Beyonce say that global
warming causes earthquakes to mention
the earth design did I hear that
correctly dramatically okay yeah
global warming or not yeah but wait till
you see my one more thing about the
telephone all right but hats off to him
well